on this thursday night an exodus of
refugees from ukraine we've got
thousands of people the rapidly
developing humanitarian crisis putin's
chilling words about his plan as russian
forces keep bombarding cities
and the international criminal court
fast tracks its investigation into
possible war crimes
suffocating russia's economy how russian
people and businesses are being hit plus
desperation and discrimination it's very
frustrating racism against some of the
people seeking refuge
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
an ominous development tonight in
ukraine this is a close circuit camera
shot of the fire that has broken out at
a nuclear power plant the largest in
ukraine after an assault by russian
forces ukraine's foreign minister
tweeted if it blows up it will be 10
times larger than chernobyl russians he
said must immediately cease fire experts
quickly said that is not accurate that
this is a different kind of nuclear
power plant the international atomic
energy agency tweeted it is aware of
reports of shelling at the zaparozzia
nuclear power plant and is in contact
with ukrainian authorities about the
situation
vladimir putin called french president
emmanuel macron today afterward an aide
said macron believes the worst is yet to
come that putin intends to take all of
ukraine russian forces are choking off
supply lines to many cities and at talks
today it's reported russia tentatively
agreed to allow humanitarian corridors
through the fighting but there is no
ceasefire
good evening and thanks for joining us
ottawa says it is sending thousands of
rocket launchers and grenades to ukraine
and is simplifying the process for those
seeking refuge in canada the u.n says at
least a million people have fled an
exodus that was unthinkable just a week
ago our coverage begins with mike
armstrong in poland
at the border you don't feel the scale
of this crisis it's a trickle of people
crossing here it's a crush
this is one of 27 refugee processing
centers set up by the polish government
it is bus after bus of people who've
left everything behind
this family made a 1200 kilometer trip
because they could no longer take the
constant danger
the father says there were air raid
sirens at all hours he didn't want to
leave but he had to protect his wife and
three children
there are 2 000 cots inside about 700
people stayed last night the goal is to
move people out the question is to where
[Music]
this girl's family said they were
waiting for a bus they didn't know the
destination they did know it was better
than being at home no job
she says she and her family spent five
nights hiding in their basement
now the european union doesn't expect
the flow of refugees to stop until the
fighting does it's predicting up to four
million people could be forced out of
ukraine some have said it could go as
high as 7 million
but one of the most shocking parts of
this exodus is the pace the syrian
refugee crisis is still considerably
bigger but it took a month to hit the
one million mark with that crisis this
has been basically one week
now there is a considerable difference
in how ukrainian refugees are being
treated by the european union thursday
the eu approved a temporary protection
status for them it means refugees from
ukraine can apply for one-year residence
permits in any eu nation they'll also be
eligible for social programs and to work
immediately that protection could be
extended to two years if the conflict
continues
there are also refugees who haven't made
it out one relief group estimates there
could be more than four million people
displaced inside ukraine and many more
who can't even leave their homes there's
hope russia sticks to thursday's
agreement for humanitarian corridors
that would help civilians perhaps not
get out of the country but at least get
further from the fighting
mike armstrong global news korshkova
poland
on russian tv today vladimir putin
repeated his view that ukraine is not a
real country and he denied russian
troops or targeting cities or killing
civilians that is clearly not true
russian forces haven't taken the capital
but they continue to bombard multiple
cities and ukraine's president keeps
appealing to the west for more help
asking for planes to fight the invasion
jeff semple reports
this dash cam video captured the moment
the bombs hit
striking a residential neighborhood in
this north ukrainian city
witnesses said the targets included
apartment buildings and a hospital more
than 30 people were killed
this nearby school was also hit by one
of around 500 rockets american officials
say russia has fired over the past week
they can hit anywhere and there is no
location here
which where you can feel safe this
security analyst lives in ukraine's
second largest city she recorded these
videos and told global news they've lost
electricity and are running out of food
there is no possibility to leave the
city in a safe manner because the the
whole city is under the constant
bombardment but she and other civilians
may soon have a chance to escape
ukrainian officials met their russian
counterparts for a second day of
negotiations and agreed to create
humanitarian corridors for civilians to
get out and aid to get in
the ukrainian president called on
vladimir putin to meet with him to
negotiate an end to the invasion
russia's missile and bomb strikes are a
confession that they have failed to do
anything substantial on our soil he said
but others don't share that optimism
explosions heard from kiev are growing
louder as the russian military inches
closer to the ukrainian capital
the russian president told his security
council the military operation is going
according to plan the next 24 to 96
hours are going to be very telling about
really the emerging russian strategy
about 90 of the russian forces that had
massed around ukraine are now reportedly
inside the country if the ukrainian
resistance stiffens
this is going to get extraordinarily
bloody and we're talking thousands if
not tens of thousands of casualties jeff
semple global news
the russian people are getting a very
different view of this war media outlets
are forbidden from even calling it a war
or an invasion the kremlin uses fear and
intimidation to control the narrative
protesting the war is also illegal this
is saint petersburg police have arrested
thousands of anti-war demonstrators in
russia
eric sorenson on how vladimir putin is
pushing his people into a conflict many
russians don't want
any hope that images of ukrainian
suffering
or that global repudiation of russia's
invasion might change the course of the
war is vanishing after speaking with
russian president vladimir putin for 90
minutes french president emmanuel macron
believes the worst is yet to come that
putin wants control of all of ukraine
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
says russia will continue the war to the
end
a solution will be found is how he put
it
and while the misery in ukraine deepens
millions of russians are reaping the
hardships from a war they've been
dragged into
foreign air travel slashed shipping
deliveries cut off and ordinary russians
lining up for rubles that are losing
value by the day
everything is bad obviously she says
price is going up i don't like it
they should end the war says this woman
almost anywhere in the world now it's
not easy being russian
the yachts of oligarchs have been seized
this one in germany star athletes like
alexander ovechkin called out if they
don't condemn vladimir putin well he's
my president
but how i said like i'm not in politics
like i'm an athlete many russians are in
limbo it's my biggest passion it's my
life
vlad cheriubl is a top mountain biker a
russian who lives in canada the
governing body for cycling okayed
russians competing as neutral athletes
but he says it's still up in the air
just because i have a russian passport
basically i don't think it's fair on a
way
but i see why there is such a strong
measurements against it
if it's awkward for russians living
abroad it is life altering for those at
home simple demonstrations against the
war have brought mass arrests and
threats of forced military service
mothers with their children reportedly
detained after laying flowers at the
ukrainian embassy in moscow
it's very embarrassing
for all of us kremlin advisor andrei
kortunov has broken ranks denouncing the
war and telling sky news life will be
tough for russians all russians will be
in a difficult position and the russian
people will feel the brunt of being an
international outcast as their country
destroys its neighbor
eric sorensen global news ottawa
canada is imposing more sanctions on
russia and its ally belarus slapping a
35 percent tariff on goods from those
countries the canadian government is
also revoking their status as most
favored nation trading partner under
world trade organization provisions
simply put
this means that russia and belarus will
no longer receive the benefits
particularly low tariffs
that canada offers to other countries
that are fellow members of the wto
that's canada's deputy prime minister
she's a key player in the international
push to suffocate russia's economy and
support ukraine christopher freeland
spent time in both moscow and kiev
before becoming a politician she speaks
both languages has deep personal
connections to ukraine and is using all
of that to try to stop vladimir putin
abigail beeman reports
president putin has now become an
international pariah forceful words near
daly from canada's deputy prime minister
not content to terrorize his own people
president vladimir putin
is seeking to impose his tyranny on his
democratic freedom-loving neighbors the
battleground today
is ukraine
but this is our fight too behind the
scenes christia freeland uses another
language too
speaking her fluent ukrainian in daily
talks with senior ukrainian officials
she's the essential person for the
moment and her background almost her
whole life is leading to this point born
to a ukrainian-canadian mother who
helped draft ukraine's constitution
freeland's own time in the country began
in the pivotal 1980s attracting the
attention of the kgb they gave her the
code name freeda researching in
ukrainian archives simon miles made the
connection between freeland and freda in
this copy of a top-secret kgb internal
journal there's one case study about the
troublemaking canadian
certainly expresses frustration with her
various activities you know shepherding
newspaper reporters around the country
helping to write speeches for ukrainian
sort of national leaders
but also that she was pretty savvy she
was savvy at sort of spycraft stuff she
later became a young financial times
moscow bureau chief and wrote a book
about post-soviet russia
in 2014 in response to sanctions placed
on russia for its annexation of crimea
she was added to putin's retaliatory
list barring her from returning and now
in 2022 connections are paying off
government sources tell global news the
west's decision to sanction russia's
central bank started with a conversation
between a ukrainian minister and
freeland the pair were once young
reporters together freeland ran with his
suggestion convincing allies including
u.s president joe biden putin got caught
with his pants down
and they're scrambling the stock
market's closed over there all week and
they're not sure what to do canada is
not always top of mind on the global
stage and freeland's name was new to
this retired irs special agent but when
he learned of her role in sanctions he
says are having punishing impacts martin
shiel says he won't forget it good for
you ms friedland i'm rooting for you
abigail beeman global news ottawa
what russia's aggression means for one
of its neighbors coming up one on one
with latvia's president
how russia's invasion of ukraine ends
and whether it extends beyond ukraine's
borders is something western countries
are focused on especially another
neighbor of russia latvia canadian
troops are on the ground there as part
of a nato mission mercedes stephenson is
also in latvia and she spoke with the
country's president mercedes
donna ilslevitz is the president of
latvia a small baltic country with a
population of less than 2 million that
shares borders with both russia and
belarus
in an interview with the west block
today he called russia's attack on
ukraine an attack on all democracies
saying now is the time for europe and
canada to stand together to stand up for
our way of life together
we are
the basis
for the western
value system
and we
should defend our values president
lovitz discussed vladimir putin's use of
disinformation and name-calling he says
the world sees putin now for what he is
putin and
russian officials are lying and the
whole world knows that everybody who is
who disagree with putin's eu is called
nazi it's ridiculous russia is not the
only concern for latvia it also shares a
border with belarus today president
levitt says he no longer considers
belarus independent but rather an
extension of the kremlin and is calling
for the same sanctions as russia
belarusia has ceased to exist as an
independent country
we should see
russia politically as a part of russia
levitt says the post-second world war
global political order is changing and
so too must nato to adapt from an
organization designed to deter russian
aggression to one dealing with the
reality of it donna mercedes stevenson
in latvia thanks
coming up what evidence would it take to
prosecute russia for war crimes in
ukraine
[Music]
the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court is fast
tracking an investigation into possible
war crimes in ukraine after receiving
requests from 39 countries including
canada an advanced team has left the
hague for the ukraine region
moving so fast is unprecedented for the
court to help us understand the
implications i'm joined by payam akkavan
a professor of international law at the
university of toronto and a former u.n
prosecutor professor why do you think
the head prosecutor is moving so fast
well the
invasion of ukraine
is a humanitarian disaster of
unprecedented dimensions and
while the mandate of the prosecutor of
the international criminal court is to
investigate and prosecute international
crimes
um one aspect of that mandate is
deterrence basically to try and deter
ongoing violations so while there
appears to be
evidence that war crimes and possibly
crimes against humanity uh are being
committed uh it's important also to
signal to the perpetrators that
the world is watching that their conduct
is going to be scrutinized and that
there may be a price to pay there have
been many reports already of attacks on
civilians in ukraine is an intentional
attack on civilians a war crime
well most certainly that is
the
most emphatic war crime
but also indiscriminate attacks are
equally war crimes if you're using
weapons or methods of warfare that fail
to distinguish
between military targets and civilian
population that is also
a war crime and of course
the burden of proof is uh more
exacting
for establishing intentional attacks
against civilian populations but it's
enough to show that the attacks were
indiscriminate
about the burden of proof what is the
threshold for laying charges of a war
crime or a crime against humanity what
evidence will the investigators be
looking for will they be interviewing
witnesses
well yes the
witness testimony is always central to
establishing such a case
physical evidence video footage
there are multiple sources that go to
establishing a case
beyond a reasonable doubt
in the case of crimes against humanity
of course we're not dealing with
isolated or random war crimes but a
widespread or systematic attack against
the civilian population
so there has to be a significant volume
of evidence which shows that
these are in fact
massive crimes that are being committed
not just at a specific location at a
specific time
but really spread across a time and a
wider geographic space
quick last question since russia is not
a member of the court and we should
point out neither is the united states
it has no legal duty then to turn over
its people for prosecution so could
vladimir putin if enough evidence is
found to convict him ever face any
punishment
well it's a matter of speculation uh who
would be eventually the target of an
investigation
a prosecutor will typically go where the
evidence leads
but once arrest warrants are issued uh
the estate that is not a party to the
statute of the court may have no
obligation to cooperate but then that
person cannot step foot outside of that
country uh in particular in european
countries that are all members
of the international criminal court
because there they will face arrest
right professor akavan thank you thank
you
next an afghan family flees a second war
their struggle to get out of ukraine
among the exodus of people from ukraine
are some who don't call the country home
there are foreign students and workers
who found themselves caught in the
conflict and there's at least one family
who fled the war in afghanistan hoping
to make it to a new life in canada none
of their journeys have been easy redmond
shannon reports
afghan refugee mir safi spoke with
global news earlier this week as his
seven family members including a newborn
baby slept on the floor of a ukrainian
school near the polish border safi says
they were blocked from leaving ukraine
four times in the past week there have
been many reports of non-ukrainians
facing discrimination while trying to
leave particularly visible minorities
it's very frustrating to see ukrainians
cross the border without being asked to
stop but me as an afghan they stopped me
and they say my baby daughter does not
have papers the safy's daughter sumiya
was born one day before the invasion
this was all the ukrainian border
authorities they didn't even give me
time to speak the safes finally made it
out wednesday night and are now in
germany
for the saffies this is the second
traumatic departure in six months they
fled the taliban last august and applied
to come to canada hoping to have been
approved long before now will the
minister look into this case and help
this family and others like them come to
canada expeditiously we can't discuss
the specifics of any case i'm happy to
look into whatever sensitive cases
may come across our desk
just like the hawk malls whom global
news spoke with in february the safies
are unsure when their case will be
processed two families praying to find
peace caught up in two brutal conflicts
redmond shannon global news london
there are so many individual stories in
this exodus tonight we leave you with
what's happening at the central train
station in berlin germany
thousands of people showed up to meet
trains filled with refugees from ukraine
who fled with almost nothing berliners
are opening their homes holding up signs
offering rooms and
opening their hearts
we cannot just sit at home and just look
at the news on the right side there is
like thousands of people from berlin
offering place to stay this is
absolutely incredible
food medical aid guidance and friendship
a safe haven and a sign of this war's
immense and continuing cost
thanks for watching
you